Ohohohohoh!!
It actually worked! Hey, what's up guys, welcome back
I need to start off this video today by telling you a little story about when my wife and I were camping with our kids
In the woods. Now apparently we had enough reception because I got a notification that my friend Mark Rober
Posted a video on the worlds largest Super Soaker. So I went over to check out his video
And it absolutely blew my mind. Not only did he make a monster Super Soaker,
He made one that actually works. But that's not even the funny part.
I literally laughed out loud when he said he put links in the description for anyone who wanted to try making something similar.
"I'll put a link to the CAD files we made along with a build list of all of the components we used in the video
description if you want to make something similar. if you want to make something similar.
(Slowed down) If you want to make something similar." Who in their right mind would actually make one?
Well, we did!
[Music]
Welcome to the "Nitro Pressure Random Blaster 5000". This thing is over 4 feet tall, 7 feet long, and slings water at 2,400 PSI.
Rather than taking six months to build, we were able to put it together in six days.
Let me show you some of its features.
We made the handle grips for the gun out of diamond plated floor matting, the rest is built out of foam, all hand-carved foam,
Painted with house paint and then sprayed with black and yellow paint to match the King of Random colors. The trigger
Here is mainly for decoration, the button
That actually shoots the water is right up top here, and when you press that it shoots out a burst at 2400 PSI.
That's a lot of pressure.
It's like explosive pressure. Piggybacking off Mark's design we use a pressure washer nozzle, so we could get a long thin stream
That would last longer, or you can change out the nozzle to something wider that dumps all the water very quickly,
Making it a true Super Soaker.
The Barrel is just made of a cardboard tube filled with great stuff and one-inch PVC
Where we can run the pressure washer line to the end.
We did a little quick graphic design and we used a vinyl cutter to make the King of Random super logo as well as the
"Nitro Pressure Random Blaster 5000" on the side here which I think looks really cool, and down here
We did our best to imitate the original Super Soaker,
but changing the name to "Random Corp.
2017". The water system on the inside functions on the same
Principles as Mark's design we have two oxygen tanks, one that's filled with High-pressure nitrogen,
and the other that's filled with water. The
Only difference is rather than using a regulator and an actuator to get the stream water flowing we found a little device that does it
All for us. That makes everything a little more simple, a little more compact.
One of the things that surprised us when we went to build this is the instructions that we're posted in the description
Weren't actually very clear. So really, we just referenced the videos, used some artistic and creative license, and tried to replicate it as best
We could. Now theoretically we could have built this bigger, and made THE world's largest Super Soaker,
But instead we decided to build ours an inch smaller than mark so he could still retain the world record however
We did make the tank a little bit bigger
So it'll hold more water this thing is already locked loaded and ready to fire watch. What happens when I pull the trigger
or press up on the trigger as the case may be
We should water the plant
Ohh.. Rainbow
Rainbow maker that's cool
And not only that we actually made a little tripod stand to set it down on
So we have to hold it all day because this thing is heavy as we were putting this thing together
I went back and watched Marc's video and he tried shooting things like watermelons Hotdogs soda cans things of that nature to
Demonstrate the power of the water shooting up the nozzle so we went down to the store and picked up the same items ourselves
So we can put them to the test and see how our results compare
Alright now that you've seen our super Soaker king of random style. Let's pressure it up and see what it can do
Click Connect
All right next up High-powered watermelon blast
(Laughing) We need something to back that
We got watermelon guts everywhere looking at that tube. All right next up soda can
Just blew that right over. Soda can is going down.
Oh, It got me!
Oh, it got me good!
Wow, that was awesome!
You see the way it took out those soda cans like I had to place it on that one for like maybe two seconds then
It ruptured all over my face
You can see the remnants on my glasses right now
So I went for the second can it explode as well the third can exploded we still had enough water pressure
To slice halfway through a watermelon that was pretty cool
Okay, we'll do the hotdogs next then
(Laughing)
It actually worked. It sliced in ice every single one of them, did you see that?
It like rolled out of my hand in privity
That is incredible
I literally dropped those from like one inch high
and they went through the beam which was apparently so strong it just ripped them all in half.
So yeah, hot dogs big win that was a lot of fun all at one and
They smell delicious. I think I'm going to take these home and cook them up for dinner because
Those are amazing the stuff still looks half edible
It's a really interesting texture on the top where it was cut it almost tastes like it's burned
If it's possible, but it tastes really good inside
So there you have a guy's based on this set of experiments
I'd say the Random Blaster 5000
has proven itself to be a major player by the way if you want to go check out Mark's original video.
I will put his link down in the description you go say hi, and tell him Grant sent you
We shot watermelons blasted through the Ryan's we punctured soda cans
And we chopped hot dogs clean in half and now that Mark Rober and I both have two of the world's largest water guns
What do you guys think we should do with them post your comments and suggestions down below?
Hey, thanks for joining me for this video. I'll be looking for you in the next one. Talk to you then.
My sweat tastes like root beer
Hey guys, this was a huge team effort. I certainly did not make this by myself
I had a lot of people working in the background to make this project possible first of all I want to say thank you to
Nate he was the guy who actually put all the foam together and made this look as good as it did
Ben Watkins helped collect all the materials for the inside the pressure tanks the pressure hoses and made that possible and a big shout out
To my friends at Kuma films who came by with their phantom and provided some of those super slow-motion shots
You can check out Kuma films in the description below
Hey guys
I want you to be some of the first to see my next video if you haven't already clicked subscribe
And ring the bell by ringing the bell you'll get a post notification the next time I post a video
So click subscribe ring the bell and I'll key in the next video